Good morning, Boss.
Here's today's schedule.
A fitting for our opening party outfits.
Please come to the Grand Hall.
I'm going to create your outfits today.
Tell me what you're looking for so
I can design the perfect outfit for you.
A striped suit.
I want some mushroom accessories
to go with it.
Make a matching suit for Kikurage.
As long as it's black, I don't care.
I want to look strong!
I want the trendy slim look.
With a herringbone pattern on a thick...
Lots of jewels! A tiara! Fur!
Something angelic, I think.
Why are you here?
I have to go to try and renew
my partnership with you!
Four years ago, you kept me locked up
and didn't let me go.
There's no way you'd be able
to be my Partner.
En.
Are you still looking for
a Sorcerer who can control time?
He doesn't even exist.
No, I know he does.
And I'm going to find him.
Next, let me take your measurements.
Bust, 62 cm.
Bust, 104 cm!
-Hey.
-Huh?
Boss, a word.
I'm busy now. It can wait.
It's about the smoke shop
you acquired the other day.
And signs of a Sorcerer
who can control time...
Those looking for a partnership
with a Sorcerer in the En family,
please submit an application form
and a sample of your Magic.
DONE
SMOKE CHECK
-Pass.
-Here's an invitation to the party.
Fail!
Try again in four years.
This is the tasting for the opening party.
For the appetizer, we have
sautéed guinea fowl and porcini mushrooms.
And our dear Boss, made from candy.
Wonderful.
DUO WEEKLY
My lucky color is yellow,
and my lucky items are leather shoes.
Beautiful!
We will decorate the path
with these flowers.
Here's the rehearsal for
the traditional play, Blue Night Miracle.
"The sky shined blue with bugs."
This again?
"The two Devils decided to work together."
-Yah!
I'm getting sleepy.
"And so, the two reigned over Hell.
The end!"
What a busy day.
The Sorcerer that can control time.
They said he didn't exist.
But if he actually does...
This year's Blue Night.
Something that's never happened before
just might happen.